klaus was ist deine meinung zu dieser
diskrepanz dass jens spahn im zum einen
einfach sagt er möchte die epidemische
lage beende auf der anderen seite die
maßnahme aber irgendwie durch die
hintertür weiter durchboxen gutes zieht
sich ein bisschen durch seine ganze
amtszeit also er tut etwas und dann ist
es aber doch anders also das ist
irgendwie
vereinfacht und etwas flapsig
zusammengefasst teil seiner
regierungszeit jetzt muss man dabei 1
aussagen aus seiner perspektive heraus
glaube ich es so analysieren zu können
sieht doch für sich jetzt ist es das
ende meiner amtszeit ich werde nicht
mehr gesundheitsminister sein es ist
überhaupt ganz unklar was ich sein werde
also ziehe ich doch mal für mich eine
spannende persönliche bilanz ich war
gesundheitsminister und ich war
natürlich erfolgreich da kam diese große
pandemie dann haben wir viele hürden
übersprungen haben gehandelt waren für
die menschen da und mehr oder weniger
gut sind wir doch dass diese pandemie
bekommen durch mich jens spahn und jetzt
zum ende meiner amtszeit erkläre ich
natürlich die pandemie für erledigt denn
durch mein gutes handeln sind wir in
diese situation gekommen dass wir jetzt
sagen können die epidemische lage ist
beendet und dann greift die realität des
infektionsschutzgesetzes wie wir gerade
gehört haben und natürlich sind die
länder dann noch in der lage etwas zu
tun und das ist etwas was als bürger die
sorge über den tag hinaus machen muss
finde ich denn das ist die
festschreibung eines freiheitsberaubung
des instruments das gab es vorher nicht
das war vor der pandemie nicht da das
ist durch das infektionsschutzgesetz
eingeführt worden und es muss mit ende
der pandemie auch wieder verschwinden
weil es sonst eine ermächtigung funktion
des staates beinhaltet die auch auf
andere bereiche anwendung finden kann
wenn man sich der logik erst mal
geöffnet hat und das macht mir wirklich
sorgen also ich verstehe ihn sparen das
haben wir festgestellt hat ich war gut
und deshalb ist die pandemie jetzt
erledigt und ich verstehe auch dass es
in der länderkompetenz ist da muss es
jetzt aber damit genauso großer hingabe
aus dem gesetzes werken raus wie es rein
kam sonst haben wir ein erbe der
pandemie dass ein ungutes ist
auch cdu urgestein klaus klaus braucht
was sage ich schon wolfgang bosbach hat
sich gestern sorgen um die einschränkung
dieser freiheitsrechte gemacht in
unserem talker bild live viertel nach
acht wir haben kurz drin
ich habe nur eine andere sorgen nämlich
dass wir uns langsam daran gewöhnen dass
der begründungspflicht ist der seine
freiheitsrechte der namen spruch neben
möchte der regelfall muss genau
umgekehrt sein der staat muss begründen
warum er in die freiheitsrechte der
bürger eingreift genau der punkt besser
kann man es kaum formulieren absolut
also ich möchte schon dass wir nach der
pandemie in einem so freiheitlichen
landleben wie vor der pandemie sonst
hätte die pandemie mit ihren auch
schlimmen folgen an sich eine wesentlich
schlimmere hinterlassenschaft als uns
das allen lieb sein kann aber warum hat
denn die bundesregierung offensichtlich
so ein problem damit uns unsere
freiheitsrechte wieder zurückzugehen
naja ich glaube die für die
bundesregierung spricht hier ja
entspannt aber ich glaube dass einfach
diese sorge dieses wabernde pandemie
das kennt man eigentlich nur aus
horrorfilmen das ist nie zu ende gehen
und diese deutsche idee dass man alles
sozusagen hundertprozentig beherrschen
muss das kommt hier um gut zusammen ich
meine persönliche eindruck aus vielen
gesprächen und viel lektüre ist dass
sich die pandemie erledigt hat wir sind
jetzt wieder im normalzustand und
deshalb müssen wir uns auch verhalten
dürfen wir im normalzustand und deshalb
muss die politik auch wieder normal
werden so wie vor der pandemie
[Musik]